[Music]
foreign
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the guardian
columnist so Williams and the former
conservative MP who's now chief
executive of the charity business in the
community Mary McLeod they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's take a look at the front pages for
you now the sun carries further extracts
from its interview with Phillip
Schofield in which he says he's afraid
to leave home for fear of being spat on
the mirror pictures Scofield's former
co-presenter Alison Hammond in tears on
live television this morning as she
discussed the story
the telegraph reports that the
government set up a disinformation unit
during the pandemic which the paper says
was aimed at stamping out lockdown
skepticism on social media
the eye carries polling suggesting the
majority of respondents believe brexit
is the main reason for increased food
prices
the mail says another year of whale
strikes could be on the cards
Express credits its own advocacy for
banks increasing of their savings rates
the times has news of a blood test that
could identify more than 50 different
types of cancer and save thousands of
lives
the guardian has details of that new
breast cancer drug which it's believed
could boost survival rates from the
disease
the financial times understands the head
of America's intelligence agency the CIA
made a visit to China last month that
wasn't disclosed in advance
and the star questions the Life Choices
of the 13 of people who've confessed to
putting tea or coffee on their cereal
yuck says my director a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us and we are
joined tonight by Zoe Williams and Mary
McLeod welcome to both of you I won't
get you to comment on the uh to your
coffee on cereal um perhaps at another
time we'll start with the sun though and
the Philip Schofield story is um still
making the front pages uh Zoe this
coming after the television interview
that he's given saying that he's he's
fearing for how the the public will
react to him now if he goes out in
public
object lesson in how not to deal with a
story he you know he sort of wasn't
straightforward his his initial
statement on Instagram was extremely
confusing
um he talked about lying to his
employers lying to Holly Willoughby
lying to his wife and it wasn't really
plain what the what what the situation
was you know if he was a guy who was you
know not out of the closet in a bad
marriage then that's one kind of lying
and if he was a guy in breach of his
employment that's another kind of lying
and if he was a guy lying to his friend
that's another category again and it it
all seems to have come out at such a
tumble that he's suddenly kind of a hate
figure number one and I can see why he's
extremely
um I can see why he does Fear being spat
on
I have to admit I really mourn
pre-social media days I'm old enough to
say that when things came out a little
bit more slowly and people digested
things a bit more
um calmly and somebody didn't have to be
100 devil or 100 angel in order to exist
in the public domain I think he's I've
got no idea what the truth is because
obviously these are personal matters and
and we can't know until we know but I do
feel for the guy
yes he has vowed regarding social media
to never again use it
um we've heard quite a bit more from him
now and obviously that the Contrition is
there
do you believe that this should be the
the end of the story now Mary
well I do I mean I think it's we've
we've heard this story for our days now
and it just seems to be relentless as he
said himself he admitted to it now
um and has said he's done a bad thing I
mean the interview he's done it was
quite difficult to listen to because
um yes it's absolutely important that
um ITV we look at how they handled it
but it's you know he's someone who is at
Rock Bottom he's apologized already he
says he did a bad thing and and you know
I just think the his his own sort of
mental health right now is something
that a people should be you know more
aware of and I think it does bring into
question in some of these stories just
rightly you know they can come out in
the media and be talked about but how
many days does it need to go on for and
how much scrutiny and that intensity of
the scrutiny that people feel they are
human beings as he said and therefore
you know are we dealing with them in a
human way and I mean on the other hand
of course ITV need to look at things
like the Peace of power in the workplace
um and how they've handled the
investigation but they said they
questioned him several times so they
felt they did what they could at the the
time
um but you know I think it's the the
four shove whether it's media attention
public attention I can well imagine that
influence doesn't feel he can't go
outside and and I think we have to
whilst we see we can see things were
wrong and what he did and I just think
that we have to also look at how he has
to live his life as a human being and
and just pull back a bit on that
intensity of scrutiny that he's getting
right now okay let's turn to the times
now and uh politics Zoe this story Boris
Johnson is
um well he has actually sent his
WhatsApp messages to the covert inquiry
circumventing the cabinet office
I mean you know people talk a lot about
the role WhatsApp plays in government
now because it's not subject to foi
legislation unless you use it on your
laptop unless you use it on your desktop
unless you move it to your computer it
is not in the public domain
um most MPS do most MPS expect it to be
a lot of MPS would absolutely be
crucified if you saw the full extent of
their private WhatsApp messages as we
saw with Matt Hancock of course
um so I think Johnson probably thinks
he's scoring a win for his own
transparency in doing this but I my
personal feeling is that the the kind of
public trust in him is so low that
whatever he does you'll imagine that he
has like a back door somewhere where
he's deleted a load of messages or
you're it he'll he'll have some kind of
other messaging service where he he did
his really compromising messaging
um he's just never gonna claw back
public opinion in favor of him as the
truth teller against the cabinet office
that's completely impossible so exactly
what his play is here I don't know
Mary your thoughts do you think he
should be commended for for doing this
or as uh Zoe's um suggesting is there
some subplot
I don't know I think that um these days
I mean I think the the inquiry have
asked for it
um and therefore I think that therefore
they need to to get it and the cabinet
office will be looking just to see is
this creation of president for the for
the future there'll be a lot of these
what's up messages that are irrelevant
so therefore you know how much
information do they do they need but I
think that's good he's he's done that it
shows if nothing else that he's not
trying to hide any information that a
that might be you know useful in that
inquiry the inquiry is going to take a
long time
um it's you know the last sort of module
of the six modules won't start until
2025 when they're looking at PP and Care
Homes so the the the the more
information they can get the more
thorough that it will be and therefore I
think that people will believe it more
and in terms of what it does I just
really wish these these inquiries would
take a shorter amount of times that we
can get to some answers quicker but
there's probably just a lot of
information in to to go through as as
part of this but a but I think for the
moment yeah he's done the right thing
yes and certainly uh families who lost
loved ones during the pandemic will want
the inquiry to to come to to findings as
soon as let's look at the Telegraph and
this is a story about
um the government setting up a covert
disinformation unit this is at the
height of the pandemic to basically curb
the criticism of um well the handling of
the pandemic and actually the the virus
itself Zoe
I think um I think they I believe they
called it the anti-disinformation unit
because their intention was that the
counter disinformation unit yes exactly
so their intention was that people
wouldn't be running Wildfire all over
Twitter saying vaccines don't work
saying lockdowns don't work saying masks
don't work
um saying you know all these things that
many people were saying the problem with
it is is that an anti-vaccination
movements were as we could see at the
time and as we know now
completely antithetical to Public Health
it was really important that everybody
took the vaccine it was really bad when
people promulgated messages saying don't
take the vaccine
other messages were a little bit more
vexed you know it's like they wouldn't
there were a number of the decent Public
Health officials saying our lockdown's
exactly the right thing when you know a
number of people are suffering mental
health loneliness crises education
crises are we balancing the needs of the
public against the needs to fight the
virus
when you get a government unit rolling
in all of those messages and saying can
we please damp Tamp these down on social
media then you're looking at the end of
a kind of vibrant Civic discourse now
you can completely understand why the
telegraph will be innovated about that
when the telegraph you know they don't
like a nanny State at the best of times
they certainly wouldn't like the state
to be rolling in a number of discussions
and saying they were all as bad as each
other and they all needed to be closed
down but I think the Counterpoint to
that is that
social media itself was with its own
algorithms creating softening hardening
narratives with the things it promoted
and the things that suggested to people
so you have to decide ultimately in this
age of absolutely
proliferating information and opinion
who has authority to sort of direct it
and I share the telegraph's anxiety that
the government maybe didn't think hard
enough but I would certainly take the
government's authority over twitters
Let's uh move on just because of time so
we get another story in um Mary if you
don't mind it and take us to the mail
and the potential or threat of more rail
strikes um I was going to say coming
down the tracks but I'll avoid
avoid that Mary
yes so UK real strikes causing more
delays to to moral
um and and also just the the line of
another year of real strike is right so
it's you know already costing the UK 5
billion pounds as the estimate for it
um and then if you just look at us left
a little bit the second time this week
and affecting lots of things going on
tomorrow and so it it's not stopping yet
there's still more to be had on on these
strikes and but it is as disrupting for
so many people as as part and and with
with all of this you just really want to
get resolution to the issues quickly if
possible
um and to you know to really sort things
out because this is a difficult time for
a lot of people with cost of living and
in trying to get into work and it's it
it really is something that we want to
get resolved in really quickly but yeah
there'll be more disruption and they're
they're of course threatening there will
be more disruption to come and the ends
not anywhere near the site yet yes and
indeed that's the worrying prediction
that this could go on for another year
uh Mary and Zoe for the moment thank you
we're going to take a break coming up
we'll tell you why the express is taking
credit for banks increasing their
savings rates and what that may mean for
you join us after the break
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Zoe Williams and
Mary McLeod to you first of all Zoe um
for this section let's take a look at
the express and this story uh relatively
good news for Savers that is that um the
banks are going to be passing on the
higher interest rates to Savers which
they haven't been doing up until now and
the express is accrediting itself with a
champion this course
I mean it's it's hilarious the express
because nobody in the country including
the BBC Sky News
nobody hasn't put the question to Banks
why aren't your savings rates tracking
interest rates and the bank's response
has always been quite weak which is to
say they say we're very competitive with
our rates and of course they are
competitive because the other Banks
aren't putting their interest rates up
either
um it was sort of naked profiteering
which we've seen quite a lot of in the
cost of living crisis you know we've
seen energy companies that score massive
windfalls while pouring all the price
increases onto customers we've seen
supermarkets do the same and we've seen
Banks watch these interest rates which
have caused mortgage penury for so many
people and and do nothing for their own
savings rates
um it it has been quite an extraordinary
time and quite and quite a chastening
time for the kind of relationship
between
corporate accounts of themselves and
Civic Society but the idea that the
express actually pushed this agenda
forward I think is fanciful you know
it's like everybody looking at interest
rates could say why isn't that interest
rate in any way reflected in my savings
when it's reflected full well in my
mortgage Whoever has pushed it forward
or to therefore Mary it is good news
isn't it
oh definitely and I think customers will
definitely welcome it and you know I
think whether it's Banks responding to
and listening to customers it may be
partly that
um but it's it literally is something
that you know I think people customers
understood it when interest rates were
were so low but you know we want people
to save if they can and therefore it's
uh an important a point where banks are
responding to that
um to the interest rates change and
savings can and can be seen as something
that is rewarded by by a return so it is
important and I think you know banks are
are trying to mean at a time when a lot
of banks on the High Street are closing
um there's there has been criticism
thrown their way so it's certainly
something they need to respond to
customers and they will be listening in
to customers I think rather than
necessarily they expressed yes quite
I've just got time for for this story in
the times uh Zoe and tell us why the
National Portrait Gallery will not
um have a portrait of William and Harry
when they reopen
it really made me sad this story because
when you look at that when you look at
the portrait you can see it in that time
story there
it really they I you know whatever they
say about one another they do look like
they um they did get on they got you
know they they weren't sort of quite
close brothers and it just makes you it
really makes you feel
you know the human side of the rift
which has been played out so publicly
um the the the the the National Gallery
is very very kind of lukewarm and
non-specific about why they're not
putting it in you know they the
spokesperson said decisions relating to
the portraits on display are made by the
gallery's curatorial team with over 250
000 portraits we're only able to display
a small percentage now that is like
saying we don't want we don't want this
but we don't want to say why we don't
want it let's just bring um Marion
quickly on this we only got about uh 20
seconds do you think we should be
reading anything into this
I don't think so particularly I mean I
think it's they they do make the
decisions on which paintings to to put
up there but
um but uh you know as always said it's a
reminder that a the the two boys were
were very close uh to one stage and
hopefully they will be again and
um but it just shows the the history
that they've shared and that's so it's a
shame it's not going going up there but
um hopefully they will there'll be other
ones that will be will encourage people
to carry on going to the National
Portrait Gallery okay Zoe and Mary thank
you both for taking us through the
newspapers